i want to jump to this story and
announcement oh uh ladies and gentlemen
timcast.com is officially news guard
certified let's go they gave us a score
of an 82 out of 100.
uh the reason i think this warrants a
story is why they gave us an x on one
issue of gathering and presenting
information responsibly
to put it simply
we adhere to all standards of newsguard
for those that are not familiar
newsguard is a certification agency that
rates all news organizations it is used
by big tech companies to determine
whether or not you can share the content
or it gets seen by others
because in about five stories out of
four thousand it's 300
3892 stories five of them had issues
one of them i believe was a fact issue
two of them were for quoting the
president himself and two were because
we had sentences that were just a little
too similar to other organizations even
though the sentences themselves were
quite generic the reason why this is
irrelevant
this affects how we get viewed on
facebook if you share one of our
articles this is how the cathedral
operates we use newsguard as a as a bias
checker on our own it's also a shield if
we report a story that says how about
this the hunter biden laptop was
confirmed and the emails in it are are
known to be real
well if someone tries claiming we're
spreading consideracy conspiracy
conspiracy theories i need only look to
the daily mail and the new york post who
are certified by newsguard and said this
is true and then i can say take it up
with that certified agency used by big
tech companies
they claimed that because in two
articles we did a fact-based report
donald trump says quote in response to
quote that because we didn't run a fact
check we are irresponsible and sharing
misleading information because as
newsguard said trump's quotes were
provably false i said okay how about
this
we weren't doing a fact check article we
were just reporting the news but if you
want moving forward we will include a
fact check here's where it gets really
funny as i stated this is what the
institution the cathedral uses it's
funded by i believe microsoft and bill
bill gates particularly or people
mention that it may just be microsoft
in the nutrition label
and again
i i have to stress this because
this is what they they consider to be
the standard for for big tech
they had four errors outright
incorrectly labeling my job at tim cast
at vice and at fusion
falsely labeling the uh tales from the
inverted world as science fiction and
fantasy they corrected all of those
immediately only after i told them they
made the mistake they injected opinion
referring to cast castle as mundane and
the best part of the whole thing is
that's the most offensive part at all
thank you
i think it's stellar work
they have injected a false quote from me
which has to be the most egregious thing
and this is what i want to say and i
wanted to be on the record and forgive
me if it's a bit internal or esoteric to
the industry
when you have an organization that
violates its own standards and accuses
you of being irresponsible well now we
have uh the fbi i'm just kidding by the
way perhaps yes well you've got an issue
there
so let me uh i want to show you this
they say asked by newsguard about the
above unchallenged claims this was
because we quoted we said donald trump
says quote
in an email pool said we will institute
a policy immediately on all quotes
moving uh here's what they wrote on all
quotes bracket that are false bracket
moving forward to run fact checks and
we'll have those two articles updated
immediately i never said that nor did i
imply it quite the opposite i told
newsguard that if you require us to to
run a fact check on donald trump's
quotes the policy would require us to
fact check every single quote from
anyone we ever report on and we will do
that if that's what your standard
dictates that would put newsguard in an
impossible situation and potentially put
them in civil tort liability positions
so they injected a false quote from me
that said that are false which i never
said i have requested a correction twice
now on that false quote they have not
corrected it
so but tim they did not call you the
black face of white supremacy now that's
special
so give them that that should be the
blurb
this is this is the standard by which
the media operates it is impossible
standard to be that being said an 82 out
of 100 is one of the highest ratings you
can probably get we got one ding but we
have five articles out of 3892
this needs to be said so that you all
understand for one i am already
preparing litigation newsguard you are
being warned okay i will be very
distinct and clear give me standing
against wikipedia and i will launch a
lawsuit in two seconds and put my money
where my mouth is newsguard you want to
claim we are irresponsible here's what
they claimed because they alerted us to
five articles and we didn't catch them
that means we're irresponsible i got six
errors from you on your own website if
your standard is that we have to be more
responsible than you are i'd love to see
you file that in court so i can parade
it around after we file if you don't
correct this also what are the news
organizations that led us into war with
iraq what are their ratings 100 out of
100 ladies and gentlemen i give you usa
today usa today receives a 100 out of
100 credibility rating despite the fact
that on their on their page they say in
june 2022 usa today took down nearly two
dozen stories by a reporter whom the
newspaper said appear to have made up
people she quoted
newsguard fabric fabricated a quote from
me
they cl they even acknowledge usa today
fabricated stories but they are 100 out
of 100. also i would argue
that this has to put them in some kind
of
civil tort territory
i will show every single certification
they've ever given and i will show they
have no legitimate standards and i want
them in court to admit it
usa today drove that story several years
ago that black churches were being
burned because of racism and it turned
out completely totally focused there
were more mosques and synagogues that
were burned
most of the black churches that were
burned were in the forest in the woods
very few of them were burned as a result
of somebody doing it because of racism
completely set this whole country part
of the expression on fire the story was
completely and totally bogus
i am just learning that today in 2022.
and what what did they say about us we
quoted trump but didn't include context
challenging trump which by the way which
is misleading you as a a a news
organization quoting the president of
the united states either way whether
trump was right or wrong is still
covering the news and it is certainly
certainly uh less nefarious than
newsguard purposefully misquoting you i
will i will add this is part of what
gives them the credibility as their
agency but i want to stress that it's
used by these big tech companies but i
also want to stress the purpose here is
to show you what their standard is when
they claim the new york times is factual
when they claim that you say today's
factual they emailed me saying this is
this is you're gonna love this guys
because we didn't talk too much about
this before i'm gonna flip the table
first thing they tried getting us on
saying these are our fake news was that
the hunter biden laptop story they said
you claimed that hunter biden in an
email was seeking funding for bio labs
or whatever and i said well i didn't
claim that the daily mail in the new
york post did and they said that's not
been verified i said i'm sorry you
certified the daily mail and the new
york post as credible agencies which i
used in my assessment of their fact
statements would you like to now have on
the record that you don't consider your
own certifications to be viable they
immediately responded with this one's
too murky so we're going to ignore it
and i said you refuse to admit that
you're you're challenging your own
certifications
i will i you you got to understand guys
this is a this this culture war and the
issues we're facing with censorship are
deeper than just
one story about elon musk and twitter of
course they are and behind the scenes i
want i want to let you all know people
are saying like why don't you do more
put your money where your mouth is
if i i have harped on wikipedia for
defamator defamation because wikipedia
says from wikipedia on every article
that is a byline
i don't have standing to sue them you
need standing and you need injury
correct me if i'm wrong is that that's
correct why don't you have standing they
did not defend me
wikipedia their article about me is
actually
fairly neutral or opinion
veritas i believe wikipedia is i'm not
james so i don't know for sure but i
believe it's verifiably false what
they've published which means they would
have standing and then what they need to
do is challenge wikipedia's 230
protections under the grounds that
they've put their byline on the article
right not the users
as for newsguard i have done everything
to make sure that anything they do
grants me standing so i can make sure
they have to file in court why they're
lying have no standards or are factually
incorrect and then i will
we'll we'll just leave it at that for
the time being now i like newsguard in
that if they i like i like in the in the
res in the respect that
we'll use them and i'll say don't look
at me they're the ones certifying it
i'll pass the buck to them that's what
they are the responsibilities they are
taking and i can respect that but don't
come to me and tell me there is no
standard by which we can be deemed a
credible news organization when you have
lower standards for other organizations
that i find to be slanderous and
defamatory and the fact that they
fabricated a quote from me crossed the
line i was content with saying they need
to correct this earlier today until i
read they fabricated a quote for me to
protect their asses
did they take a quote and then add stuff
to it yup what do they add exactly they
added bracket that was false to imply oh
bracket so they're assuming you implied
that which is also i believe
i would argue maybe even grounds for
malice because what i actually said was
it's an impossible standard but we'll do
it
to add those words is to imply my
statement was actually that we will
begin fact-checking false statements
that we weren't fact-checking before but
i mean it is to imply that i was
accepting false statements
no so no we have a corrections policy
and we don't allow false statements but
you can't know if something's false
until after you fact-check it exactly
it's ridiculous because they knew my
statement to be included would show that
they have have broken standards they
they put a fake quote in place i'm not
standing for that they're hopeful i have
some basis for a lawsuit after my
campaign for governor i was just a
scotch under a million followers on
twitter over the next several months i
lost about 30 000
and i still lose about 100 per day
however a few weeks ago when elon musk
announced his intention to buy twitter i
gained 10 000 followers within 24 hours
how does that happen you're not alone
how does i know
uh and a lot of conservatives gained a
lot of and a lot of liberals lost a lot
of followers in one fell swoop within 24
48 hours that is some severe neglig some
malpractice tell me about it
something something
we're going to go to a class action
thing
i've got to we're going to super chats
but um youtube has been breaking on us
so
before we do larry what's your mom's
name because i want to attribute that
quote to her viola elder can you say
that quote one more time
like the instrument yeah do you want to
say it the truth will not set you free
if delivered without hope yes so we've
been my my husband and i have been
having an ongoing conversation over
whether facts care about your feelings
and i argue that you can't convince
someone of a fact unless you also care
about the feelings kind of like what
maya angelou said she said people will
you know forget what you said don't
forget what you did but they'll never
forget
my mother couldn't stand maya angelou
yeah and i understand i thought she was
phony yes by the way you know you know
she's not a doctor i call her a doctor
she's in no degree oh really my mother
thought she was completely phony thought
her accent was all made up she my mother
couldn't stand her yes can you guys call
me doctor from now on i'll call you
anything you want
hell yeah
angelo
biola v-i-o-l-a yes nice so i don't like
to use that my angelou quote because i
don't like her either but i think she
has a point and that people don't really
care if you're presenting them with
facts if you appear to not care about
how they feel right now well that's why
comedy can be so powerful right it's
like it evokes a physical feeling and
then if you can laugh together chances
are you can figure some stuff out and it
would be nice it's nice if late night
comedy wasn't so far to the left well
it's only one it's great gutfelt the
only one that's late night that that
that is not left-wing yeah well
about 15 of young people admit that they
get their primary source of news from
the monologues larry i would like to
argue that they are also not funny so
not technically
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you